do you want to marry a virgin definitely
yes yeah
absolutely I mean it's not the end-all
thing but if it's uh if I found the girl
and I was gonna like it regardless I
mean then yeah that's just I would say
would you guys be willing to like wait
then until you're married to sleep with
her
ooh
that's usually what comes with a virgin
like if if she's she's usually waiting
so like typically
um like my friends that were virgins
when they got married like the dude
dated them for a year a year and a half
then they got married so he didn't do
anything with anyone else for a year
year and a half
it's an interesting question because
like personally I just don't think
marriage is advantageous I'm from Canada
right and so the family court system
they're just not in the benefit of men
so I just don't believe in marriage but
I think my ideal partner that I want to
like kind of like emotionally
spiritually settle down with you know
ideally would have a lower body count
what what if um maybe marriage it
doesn't have to be like marriage in the
church sure because like those girls
typically want to get married in the
church sure yeah I mean would you be
willing to wait like a year year and a
half to be with that girl I think so
yeah okay are you being honest though
oh
yeah
that's no that's impossible the only the
only yeah yeah like okay the only reason
I ask is because a lot of guys like say
they want virgins but I don't think they
want what would come with it and I know
a lot of girls that are virgins and did
wait till they were married because I
went to Catholic school and just like
different churches have been involved in
I'm like I don't think a lot of the guys
that say they want virgins would do the
stuff they'd be like they would want I
mean talk about your ex-girlfriends yeah
if you can
yeah talk about us girlfriend
um yeah my ex-girlfriend was a virgin
when I met her okay
um so it's not like and is she still a
virgin no I I took that okay fair enough
yeah yeah but
um I don't know I'm kind of on board
with what Justin was saying about the
whole marriage system like I'd want to
do in the church for her and you know
have the big party and you know give her
the memories and whatnot but in terms of
like actually signing a legal binding
contract to a government I that doesn't
really interest me too much yeah no I
agree I don't think it's advantageous
for men like if I was a guy I probably
wouldn't want to get married
um but it's interesting that what you
say about guys one in the Virgin but not
being willing to wait for the virginity
like that's like yeah a year and a half
sounds like a long time it does that
means we'd have to bump that marriage up
but do you think that's because you've
experienced sex already
um probably
um yeah so now you know what it is you
know what you're going to be missing
right yeah
and I think that's a lot of what because
uh remember last show we had Linda on
and she was a virgin and
um I was actually speaking to her after
the show
and it's just interesting
the way guys are like if
we speak at statistics right and
marriages often work out if the two
people that get together in a marriage
are are virgins yeah it's like the the
highest
the success rate is when they're both
virgins yeah yeah so if one has already
experienced sex and the other one hasn't
their marriage is less likely to work
out
yeah I believe that that makes sense
why are you laughing sorry because that
makes no sense to me whatsoever I really
why tell me why
I'm like why would she even like I just
I wouldn't not even consider someone how
how many like if someone's a virgin or
not if I like I I don't bump into any of
you and say hey are you a virgin no but
when you're getting to know somebody you
would ask a question though
you don't want to know if the woman that
you're with is a virgin or she's had sex
with a hundred thousand men like
so you you would marry a girl that had
sex with a hundred guys
why why is the number like I I'm yeah so
I just yeah that's a completely abstract
concept to me do you want to talk about
pair bonding bro no it was because I
only got like yeah I only discovered who
you were yesterday and yeah like yeah
and like even the the idea of that yeah
whatever bonding is intriguing to me
because it's a completely firing concept
okay
it's just in my entire life yeah it's
just basically like the more partners
that a girl
um has the more people she Compares him
to typically and it makes her less
satisfied with the guy she's with so for
example if a girl is a virgin when she's
married she has an 80 chance of having a
happy marriage after 10 years where if
she slept with more than five people it
drops to a 30 chance how are you how are
you ascribing these statistics to that
like what's the like how how do you
possibly prescribe an 80 statistical so
so they they survey the people later
so like how many people did you slept
with when you got when you got married
and then later they come back and ask if
they're happy are they reducing that to
just sex and saying that the reason the
women are comparing them to the Past man
is specifically because of sexism well
okay they don't they don't they they
don't say in the study that it's because
they compare so I should say that's just
like based on like my like talking to
people
um it's just based on how many partners
they've had so it drops down to 25
it's just very harmless Simpson telling
Kent Brockman that like 40 of all people
can make up statistics like so yeah so
you don't see the you don't see the
sense in it so if if you think that
somebody has experienced a hundred men
for instance yeah if a woman's
experienced 100 men yes and then you're
101. yeah you don't think that those 100
men would
um she won't think about one of those
100 men
and not you and not you of course you
would but right exactly so that's that
but but that that it's complete it's it
does it's a it's a fallacy it doesn't
like it it's not a comparable statistic
well well of course it is because do you
know what an alpha Widow is a what Alpha
Widow an alpha Widow yeah so uh a lot of
women a lot of women have gone Pearl
you'll explain it better than they would
well it's basically like like women like
to be with a guy that's the best that
they can get
and like they want to feel like they're
with who the best the best that they can
get and the problem is if a girl has a
guy that's at a certain caliber and then
she goes on to date somebody else and
she sees him as settled so a lot of
times women sleep up
and then the person that they marry
isn't who they actually want and so
there's like accounts of like like even
there's Reddit threads of like girls
talking about how they you know married
one guy and they miss their husband or
not sorry they miss their ex-boyfriend
from college or whoever it was but what
is why does sex or how many people
they've slept with determine that
wouldn't it be other factors
if you've had a hundred guys but not all
of those are going to be substantial
relationships not all those are going to
be comparable to say the person you're
one specific person you're always no
different for one person sleeping with
one person and comparing that to that
person right what do you do so and so
say if they um had only slept with say
like five people before they met the
person they married right um regardless
of whether they slept with a hundred or
five there's still that one boyfriend
that they'd compare to you're actually
you're actually correct with that it's
not it's not necessarily only about the
number like if you know the first person
you slept with was Michael B Jordan I
think it's going to be hard to live up
with up to that if that's your first
boyfriend so it's not necessarily about
the number but when you go up to a
hundred it's like the the more chances
of there being a guy that you can't live
up to I think increases I think if women
are actually honest they all know that
one guy in their head that they probably
won't say there's that one guy that they
know who we're actually talking about I
don't know who he is but you do I think
it's it's depending on how you view your
past relationships for me there's not
one in my life I would really want to go
back to because I understand why it
didn't work out and and it worked out
didn't work out for specific reasons and
I'm not quite frankly that person
anymore and I also think it's dependent
on the circumstances of how women are
sleeping with these different men right
if they're not entering into emotional
commitments or you know why they're
sleeping around these sorts of things
and then they change the headspace that
they're in then I don't think body count
has an impact on who their future
partner might be based on just oh like
self-awareness as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible